hallo ich
bin immer wenn und ja
jeder alles gute nachträglich zum
eurovision song contest sieg
denn auch die fragen die kommen nicht
von mir sondern sind fragen aus meiner
klasse
ich fange jetzt einfach mal an okay wenn
ich du dir manchmal ein altes leben
zurück also noch nicht und man nicht so
bekannt war ist
wünsche ich mir im moment gar nicht
zurück alles alles wünsche ich mir also
ich wünsche mir mein eigenes leben nicht
zurück ich habe das alte leben ja noch
aber ich habe jetzt zusätzlich noch ein
paar neue sachen und das find ich ganz
schön gut zweite frage ist
ja in facebook und myspace
und unseren kam halt
wer kümmert sich eigentlich um die
account also machst du das oder man sich
irgendwelche anderen körper
gut
also zum beispiel es gibt ja so
fanseiten auf myspace und facebook und
die machen auf jeden fall andere leute
aber das heißt ja nicht dass ich da und
ich lege mich drauf gucke also ich gucke
mir das regelmäßig an was dazu
geschrieben wird von den fans zum
beispiel
und dann habe ich noch eine eigene
private facebook seite aber die die
öffentlich ist und wo man nicht an glück
liegt ein freund werden oder zu freunden
hinzufügen sondern ein fan werden die
mache ich nicht selber
viele dritte frage
hast du ein großes vorbild und wenn
wähle
ich habe kein großes vorbild ich habe
ganz viele leute die ihre musik ich toll
finde und und deren schaffen ich
bewundere aber ich habe keinen kein
künstler oder keinen musiker den ich als
mein großes vorbild sehen würde und zu
dem ich sagen würde du bist so toll ich
möchte genau so sein wie du
fertig das wars okay das war's
und bleib so wie du bist